let's say that I had the number 0.17 how
could I say this number I said it one
way I said 0.17 but what are other ways
that I could say it especially if I
wanted to express it in terms of tenths
or hundredths or other places and like
always try to pause the video and try to
think about it on your own
alright so there's actually a couple of
ways that we could we could say this
number one is just to say zero point one
seven other ways or to say look I have a
1 in the tenths place so that's going to
be 1/10 1/10 and 1/10 and I have a 7 in
the hundredths place so this is a 7
right over here in the hundreds place so
I could say one tenth and seven
hundredths hun on Dritz and there you go
that's one way to say this number now
another way to think about it is just
say the whole thing in terms of
hundredths so 1/10 is how many
hundredths well a tenth is the same
thing as 10 hundredths so you could say
you could say instead of 1/10 you could
say this is 10 hundredths and the way
I'm writing it right now very few people
would actually do it this way 10
hundredths and and seven hundredths and
seven hundredths well now I could just
add these hundreds if I have ten
hundredths and have another seven
hundredths that's going to be 17
hundredths so I could just write this
down as 17 hundreds hundreds and to make
that intuition of how we could just call
the 1700s instead of just calling it
1/10 and seven hundredths let's actually
count by hundredths so that is one
hundredth that is two hundred and
actually let me just go straight to nine
hundredths so I've skipped a bunch right
over here and what would be the next how
would I say ten hundredths
well 10 hundredths let me write this way
10 hundredths is the same thing as 1/10
so if we go from 9 hundredths the next
if I'm counting by hundredths the next
one's going to be 10 hundredths now once
again 10 hundredths is the same thing as
1/10 this the same way that 10 ones is
the same thing as 1/10 I hope that
doesn't confuse you but we could keep
counting 10 hundredths 1,100 1,200 1,300
1,400 1,500 1,600
and then finally 17 hundredths so
hopefully that gives you a little
intuition for why we can call this
number instead of just calling it zero
point one seven or one tenth and seven
hundredths we could call this 17
hundredths so with that other way let's
do a couple of examples going the other
way let's say we're given a name of a
number or the words and we want to write
it down as a decimal so this is four
tens and three hundredths all right so
four tens so the for tens right over
here so actually let me just put some
places over here so this would be if
this is our tens place and then this is
our ones place and then you're going to
have your decimal and then you're going
to have your tenths place tenths place
and then you're going to have and I'll
do this in a different color
your hundredths place Hunn under its
place so we're going to have four tens
not tenths four tens so four tens
zero ones zero once we got our decimal
they don't have any tenths over here so
zero tenths and then we have three
hundredths three hundredths so three
hundredths so four tens which is the
same thing as forty and three hundredths
right over here so forty point zero
three let's do another one of these this
is kind of fun so we have 24 hundredths
24 hundredths so by the logic that we
saw in
first one in the first one we could just
write this as remember this would be
nine hundredths and if we want more one
more hundredths this would be ten
hundredths so if we want to do 24
hundredths it would just be zero point
two four and if you're saying well wait
this looks like two tenths and four
hundredths you'd be right but remember
so actually let me I could rewrite this
as I could rewrite this as to two tenths
two tenths and four hundredths let me
say and four hundredths unn drifts but
remember a tenth is equal to ten
hundredths so two tenths is the same
thing as 20 hundredths hundredths I have
trouble saying it so this is same thing
as 20 hundredths and four hundredths and
four let me write it neatly four
hundredths and of course 20 hundredths
and 400s is the same thing as 24
hundredths so hopefully that makes sense